nicole is with us in new york city hi
nicole how are you
hi dave thank you for taking the call
sure how can i help
so um i recently received inheritance
from my mother
um she passed away earlier this year
from kobe
and um so my husband and i
every once in a while we sit there and
we look at our bills
for me i don't have any credit cards i
just have my student loans
in the house and what i discovered
um my husband was able to give me any
money because at one point he had
gotten into so much debt he got a
consolidation loan and plus again it's
alimony and child support which are now
done so
um you know i do the bills and you might
sit down with the bills
every month and every every once while
he wasn't doing it with me so i finally
just set out outright
it's like what is your debt because
there's no money coming in from your
side
and now he's back in debt again so with
the inheritance i'm
i'm trying to decide whether i should
pay off my student loan
um i mean the payment's like 800 a month
or
really aggressively attack the mortgage
because i'm a little
concerned about the future we're both
50. yeah how much
student loan debt do you have um
and eighteen thousand and what is your
uh income
i make a hundred and fifty what's your
husband mike
um he's about 150 he both um
230 household income yes and your
uh inheritance is how much
um 75 000. and how much debt does he
have
he has right now um what he told me
recently is about
82 000 in credit cards okay
all right you can't make enough
or strategize enough to come out of this
disaster
with your skin intact unless he stops
being stupid
you cannot there's not a strategy that
will offset
him over spending and mismanaging at the
level that he is it's kind of like
saying
he's got cancer and it doesn't affect me
yeah it does
when somebody's got cancer everybody in
the house is affected
yes they don't all have cancer but they
all are impacted by the fact that
there's cancer in the house
and nicole your question about paying
off your house sounds like it's a
question rooted in safety
defensive mechanism because you think
he's going to continue to screw up
or he's going to bail on you um well
isn't it so earlier in our marriage only
been married um eight years
he did have an affair and he left the
house
so we reconciled the 2018 but
i told him there's reason why you have a
patent every two years
just getting in crazy debt with credit
cards and so
we're not back at that same point are
you guys have you guys seen a marriage
counselor
i've um suggested one he has it
okay um right there's two there's two
things
here's the answer to your question then
okay you do not need to pay off your
mortgage
and you do not need to pay off your
student loans you need to park the
inheritance
in a separate account with your name on
it only
and you need to demand marriage
counseling
and the two of you need to get on the
same page and you need to see a bright
hopeful future together
and then when you do that then the two
of you need to combine your incomes
and combine your goals and combine your
problems
your student loan problem his former
credit card debt problem because he no
longer is going to have one after you go
through ramsey plus and
financial peace university together and
both of you are on the same team
if your husband is unwilling to do all
of these things
see that nothing can remain in its
status quo
it can't remain where it is so your
marriage is either going to get worse
or it's going to get better i'm telling
you to take some steps to make
it better and get the two of you on the
same page with a
joint set of goals financially
emotionally maritally everything else
you do not have those now
you got one foot out the door in divorce
because the way you're preparing all of
your money stuff is as if this is ending
when you got back in touch when you got
back together with him in 2018 it sounds
like you hedged that relationship
yep that you were gonna split money you
were gonna
keep doing your thing but you would take
this guy back
because either you were lonely or you
missed him is that fair
well ash um no actually when he came
back
i was like okay we'll put the accounts
back together again because he separated
them
and then he just chose not to put the
accounts back together again so that
since 2018 um there are fractures in
your relationship that are causing you
to play
defense and i'm telling you you can't
play defense enough to solve those
you've got to solve those one way to
other but you're all going to fall in
those cracks
yeah you're going to end this thing
because it won't work
or you're going to bring it together and
heal it and figure out with some help
how to do that
and then you can have some joined goals
in the meantime i'm parking this money
over the side because i don't know what
you're going to be facing
next 12 months is going to be rowdy i
know that this is the dave ramsey show